e
everybody
okay okay I will open the hearing on the
house rules
committee and uh the first order of
business is uh requests for late
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker members of
the committee for the record my name is
Dan Maguire I represent the town of
Epsom I'm here to ask you um to let me
late draft a a bill on SAU
consolidation it's actually a bill that
I did put in during the drafting period
um but a few days later I got a note
from um OS saying we cannot draft this
because you haven't given us enough
information now I think I did I told
them you know
what the saus would look like a after
consolidation the process of
consolidating them the timeline and so
on um there's going to be new elective
offices involved in all those kind of
details but they claimed well you know
saus are mentioned 50 times in the rsas
and you didn't tell us for all of those
you know what are you going to do right
and so I I I argued with them for a
little bit and um I ended up saying okay
I'll just write it myself so in the
ensuing whatever 10 days or so I um I
put in the work and went through all of
those it's actually more like 80
references to sa use in the rsas but I
went through them all I have a draft
it's ready to go and um
it it's almost line for line of what
they're going to need to to put into the
RSA into the bill so I think that they
can do it without any further
information from this and
um so also there is some urgency right
you so you might just say well put it in
next year right but the way the timing
works on this transition period is a
one-year delay with this bill would be
more like a two-year delay because um
there's a certain election calendar
thing so so the bill makes new
superintendents elected and you they
they have to be uh start the election
process at a certain time and so on so
there's there's a there's a timeline
involved in the bill and so doing this a
year from now there wouldn't be enough
time for that process to work right and
so it would end up being like a two-year
delay so I'm asking you for permission
to late draft this
thank you for presenting this so just to
be clear though when OS said they
couldn't do it did they also just give
you a specific list of the things for
you to provide not exactly they it was
more like a list of complaints it there
was no question marks on it right they
didn't say what about this what about
that they just sort of said well you
didn't say this you didn't say that you
didn't you know it it and I and when I
talked to them it was
like it it just they weren't very
cooperative me it's it's that simple and
I just thought you know I'm not going to
say it wasn't a useful process for me to
write the bill um uh it took me a long
time
but I did actually get into all the
little places that that this uh this
touches I mean most of them I most of
them have no change because there's seus
now there will be seus later so you know
there there's no change but but some
sober thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
for taking my question I'm I'm wondering
about the timelines when was it that
they told you that they couldn't
draft and did you have an adequate
amount of time I mean you have done yeah
the answer is work and and could it have
been done but by the deadline is the
question I think not because um it was I
put this in a few days before the
deadline I heard back from them after a
day or two so there was maybe a day or
two left and and the 20 hours I put in I
didn't do it you know 20 hours straight
I did two hours a day for 10 days or
something like that you know so uh
m sweny m speak I would move to accept
drafting motion to accept
Weber although the process
is concerning and the issues with os are
concerning
um one of the things we have always held
to is um a certain factor of exigency
and I am Al although I am sensitive to
the concerns
about uh how long it takes for
implementation I don't think that that
rises to the level of
um needing late drafting this time
around as opposed to putting it in any
year here um I'm willing to be convinced
otherwise but I haven't heard anything
accept clerk usually claws the role but
you the motion is to accept the late
drafting Mr Clerk and uh could you call
the role please
representative Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne
representative Sweeney yes
representative
Simpson no representative
eel no representative Weber no
representative Sullivan
no motion carries
54 thank
you next on the agenda is the uh
amendment to house rules I believe you
it chair recognize representative Smith
for a
motion thank you Mr Speaker I move to
accept the amendment to house rule 66 as
written is there a discussion is there a
second first second second thank you uh
okay if there's no disc well
Weber I will only say that because of
the extremely long period of time for
the house to do The house's work which I
I think is very useful in some cases uh
it's going to be up to the speaker and
the committee chairs to make sure that
people don't get lulled into a false
sense of having more time and and
getting the work out and figuring out
what are time schedule is going to be
coming up to the deadline and getting
work out before the deadline but um
having said that I have no objection to
the way it's the way it's written it's
issue there any further discussion if
not clerk will call a
roll represent Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeny yes representative
Simpson yes representative eel yes
representative Weber yes representative
Zer we'll move on to a uh amendment to
house rules um this one is amendment to
house rule 28 proposed by representative
Liv and Steven
thank you Mr Speaker members of the
committee um as you all know I'm sure
last year there was an issue uh arose as
to uh
subpoenas uh issued by the legislature
when um as as I understand it a
committee chair uh determined that it
was appropriate to uh
without much discussion that to issue a
subpoena um as a result of that um I
think a number of people including
representative Smith and myself uh
concluded that we should have a change
to the rule uh dealing with
subpoenas um uh to make sure that before
that happened and before there were any
was any action taken in the event that a
subpoena was not complied with that um
there would be more centralized and uh
uh knowing basis for doing that
including making sure that the uh that
uh um leadership was uh aware of what
was going on and and uh were on board
with doing it so the the first part uh
the changes that are proposed in the
rule are the one are what is in bold um
the language in rule 20 in the rule 28
itself proper before you get to
subdivision a the Bold in bolded
language there uh was was drafted by
representative Smith uh representative
Smith and I think it um it
accomplishes
um the goal that I just spoke of in in
ensuring that uh there will be approval
uh from the rules committee um before um
a subpoena is issued um and then
um
uh the subsection a which is sort of the
enforcement me mechanism if a subpoena
is not complied with I drafted that um
basically to make certain that um before
there was any effort to hold someone in
contempt for failing to comply with the
subpoena um that um the matter had been
uh presented um to the floor for a vote
of uh of the majority of the house uh
and only then and only with the
speaker's approval thereafter uh would
appropriate action be taken um to uh
enforce to take action to enforce the
subena I should say just by way of
background that there is another stat uh
legislative change that is being
proposed as a statute uh that which the
speaker is the prime sponsor that
establishes both a criminal penalty and
a civil remedy for some someone who
without just cause fails to uh comply
with the subpoena issued by by uh either
the house or the senate or a joint uh if
there was a joint legislative committee
um and it basically it it um establishes
those um those penalties provides a
mechanism uh for in the case of a
criminal it's a it it creates a
misdemeanor offense and it requires that
uh any prosecution for uh contempt of
the legislature be brought only by the
Attorney General's office and brought
only in the marrat County Superior Court
in the case of the Civil remedy it
allows either house to uh go to court to
uh seek civil contempt remedies or uh to
ask the Attorney General again to seek
civil contempt remedies and that again
Court
pres thank you uh representative Lynn so
the legislation has been introduced but
um in the absence of that legislation
what is the
remedy well you interestingly I think
the if historically I think it's it's
generally recognized both at the federal
level and in the state that that the
legislature has the authority inherent
authority to issue subpoenas and to
compel compliance with subpoenas um in
fact if you you I in doing some research
on this apparently the it doesn't it it
happens almost never now but the um as
recently as like 1914 if I'm if I'm
remembering correctly the US the US
Congress actually sent the uh um the you
know the the Congressional Marshall at
the time out to arrest somebody who had
failed to comply with a subpoena and
that that is a proper uh uh way for the
legislature to to
operate I am not suggesting for a moment
that I think that's something that you
know we should begin employing on any
kind of a routine basis um but I think
it I think it is important to understand
that we legislators do have that
inherent Authority I think the purpose
of the statute is to is basically to say
look if if and when we ever get to those
rare situations where it it is felt the
how the house does feel or the Senate
does feel that it's necessary to hold
somebody in contempt these are the
procedures that would be that would
generally be followed would which would
involved further questions Senator
Weber I was just going to
ask I I understand your reasoning for
that but because that statute has not
yet been enacted is not the provision of
subdivision a not a little
premature um I no I don't I mean I I
guess I don't think so because if we
didn't if we didn't um if we if the
statute is passed um I think you would
want language in the rules that were
that was
consistent and and I guess the other
thing that I would say is I mean even if
the statute were not passed I think
wouldn't you want to
have something spelled out more in more
detail than it is now now as to what
happens if somebody doesn't comply with
a subpoena I mean this this is worded in
a it's worded pretty generically it says
this uh the speaker shall take
appropriate action to sanction such
conduct and enforce compliance with the
subpoena if the statute is passed the
statute sets out sort of the way that
that would happen um if the statute is
not passed I guess this you know that it
will be in the speaker's hands to
determine um what action would be
appropriate I suppose the speaker could
say if it was egregious enough could say
I'm going to you know I'm going to ask
the house to authorize me to have the
Sergeant at Arms U go out and arrest the
person who failed to comply I again I
think that would
be an extraordinary circumstance um that
would would not happen uh you know in a
in a in except in that kind of a
circumstance but I suppose this you know
this legislature does have that
constitutional Authority mat I have a
quick followup I I certainly agree that
having a um procedure available rather
than leaving it completely up in the air
is not a bad thing I I do however note
that I'm hearing Mrs Casey my sixth
grade teacher's voice in my ear saying
you can't
subdivide into an a unless there's a b
and perhaps that would be better written
as a second as another paragraph Without
a
subheading and I just note that that
because Mrs Casey is not letting me get
away with it otherwise but thank you I I
take no I mean if that if you know I
take no position on that you may be
right and that maybe it would be better
to just have it as a second paragraph
without an a I I leave that to the
committee's discretion but I I I I Don't
Really
Care thank you
Simpson yeah thank you um so I think
what I heard you say earlier is that if
this did Issue or situation did arise
that we could figure out the procedures
at that time of how we would enforce
this or how the speaker would enforce
this and I I'm concerned that um doing
that in the heat of any moment might not
be the best time to do it and that I
would want more of it to be fleshed out
in this paragraph um so the first thing
would be so
who then would be the marshals as the
marshals for the US Congress do you mean
like the sergeant of arms would be the
equivalent to the marshals I would I
would I would think so and I I guess
what I would say representative Simpson
is I think I think if you look at this
and
compare
um uh the the language I think it does
with what is there now I mean I think it
does set it does place a number of
additional restrictions over what the
what the rule says now in other words it
it requires the approval of the rules
committee um uh to before the subpoena
so a chair a chairman of a committee
isn't going to be able to decide hey you
know this is I want to I'm going to
subpoena witness X that has to uh that
has to go to the rules committee the
rules committee has to approve it the
rules committee um can set um uh
conditions on on how a subpoena should
be issued that kind of thing and then
the provision for enforcement which
right now there is no real provision for
enforcement so I suppose you know right
now um the speaker would
have um I would think more discretion
under existing procedure than under this
because this this sort of circumscribes
the speaker discretion which I think is
is the whole U the whole idea was to
make this you know to make to make sure
that this really this that in these
extraordinary circumstances where we
decided to do something like this it
was it was with you know everybody was
sort of on board and it was with the
with the approval of a majority of all
of the members of the
House other question yeah thank you um
thank you that helps um I am still
wanting a little bit higher of a bar
would you you be open to instead of it
requiring a majority vote of the entire
house um maybe a 3 fifths vote of the
house you know I would have I guess I
would have a pro personally I would have
a problem with that because I I think
it's important to understand that the
house th this inherent Authority as you
know has I think if you looked at the
you know the case law around the country
this inherent Authority has existed in
legislative bodies I think going I mean
going back to England it's it's not this
isn't something that's kind of new it's
very true that for you know thankfully
we have never uh you know had a practice
in New Hampshire of kind of employing
this on a on a willy-nilly basis or
really as far as I can recall at all um
but it's a it's an authority that does
exist and I guess I
would it seems to me that if a majority
maity of the of the members of of the
house felt that somebody was in contempt
and that some action should be taken I
would think think that that would be
enough to move the process forward uh
um holding the person in you know
sending the person for example let's
even assume it's civil cont typically
what would happen in civil contempt is
the person would be said okay you didn't
comply you didn't have any just reason
for not complying you must comply and
you know the most extreme sanction would
be for the court for the for somebody to
say you're going to jail until you
comply but that would have to be a court
the the legislature can't put somebody
in jail so it would have to be a court
that would do that it seems to me that
it's enough protection if a majority of
the legislature felt that the matter
should be referred to court and then the
court is the only one that could
actually you know sort of pull the pull
the lever so to speak and as a final
thing to say yes you are you are going
to jail until you comply um so I I I
guess I that's a long way of saying I
enough further discussion further
questions Z
Smith thanks for your presentation is
isn't the real nugget that we get out of
the other par though the house already
has subpoena power right and what's
never addressed is the house subpoenas
me and I go
now we feel like I'm in contempt of the
house but it isn't explicitly stated and
that's what this accomplishes it sure no
exactly I mean I think that's the whole
and that's the thing that's the again
the purpose of the statute is to you
know to flesh out all the things that
that that happened so I think it's very
I think it's important
further question so along those lines
then isn't it better to have the rule
before the statute so that there's
something for the statute to refer to
refer to yeah no I think this I think
that makes sense
absolutely further
discussion chair isable yes thank you um
I I'd like to support the notion of
having a three-fifth vote versus a
majority vote um I guess I mean who's to
say about anything but it seems to me
that at some level if it's just the
majority it could be used as a political
tool in some way and if you had
three-fifths of the house you would feel
more secure that it was uh a consensus
of a very large number of the house
members because being in contempt is
being held in contempt is a rather
extraordinary measure me so I would
personally feel more comfortable if it
was
35ths
motion I move to accept the amendment to
written
second sen Osborne
discussion if there's no further
discussion the clerk will call a
rooll represent Packard
yes representative Smith yes
representative duet yes representative
Osborne yes represent Sweeney yes
representative Simpson no Representative
eil no representative Weber no
representative Sullivan
move on to amendment to house rule
naer good morning Mr Speaker and
committee my um amendment to house rule
two is very straightforward it's just um
all members in the house chamber shall
be dressed in proper business
attire the House of Representatives is a
hallowed institution with a 200e history
dignity and respect should Prevail and
our dress the way we dress should
reflect that we've seen a lot of casual
clothing which cheapens the decorum
we've seen not enough clothing I've seen
ripped jeans in
committee I remember in 2008 when I was
first learning about uh New Hampshire
politics speaker Donna scitec taught a
class and she said she always wore a
jacket it doesn't mean you have to go
into Hawk to dress properly for the
house I had a friend that served her
first two terms with me she went to
Goodwill bought two jackets and she
switched them out for those two years
and then her second term she had a new
jacket so she had three to switch and
that was fine so I hope that you'll
agree with me and pass the
for Smith a
motion I move to accept the amendment to
representative Osborne oh representative
Weber oh you second second oh sorry okay
I thought there was a second oh
representative Oz one second is there
any further
discussion yes that's that's what I was
raising my hand for um as you will
remember Mr Speaker we addressed this
extensively in 2016 yes I do remember
and the issue is
uh proper business attire I am well
aware of the fact that I came from a
physical therapy appointment today and I
am wearing the equivalent of a
t-shirt um I noticed that there are
other members here who are not wearing
constructive jackets with lapels I don't
own one with lapel anymore thank god um
and I'm thinking and I actually agree
very much in principle with this because
as I tell my fourth graders we are
representing our town when we come to
the legislature and we want to represent
our town and be respectful but I am
thinking of the innumerable
layers of what I think of as proper
business attire and what other people
may think of as proper business attire
and the people who may run a foul of it
either because of uh medical conditions
that requires special shoes or less
shoes than any of us would rather people
had on or um other things like that I'm
also thinking
of um the number of people for example
who wear athletic shoes as opposed to
what I think of as business shoes and
finally with respect to the point about
going to Goodwill for the
jackets um every one of us makes a
financial sacrifice to serve this place
and for some of us that sacrifice is a
great deal more than for others but the
whole having to figure out whether it's
Goodwill whether it's something
else it's demeaning to have to make
those kinds of considerations and I'm
concerned about that for those members
who are making a really difficult
sacrifice in in order to serve in this
place so for those reasons I think if if
you would want to prescrib no blue jeans
or no ripped clothing although I
remember a member who as a matter of
religious observants wore a sweatshirt
that had its sleeves snipped out
um I think without knowing exactly what
proper business attire is you Mr Speaker
are going to have a tough time of it so
uh for that reason I'm although I
support it in principle I personally
discussion
I Simpson up
first um so my concern is how uh this
will be fleshed
out uh I'm concerned of who is is going
to make the specific decisions about
what business attire is so I'm thinking
of the um like school dress codes where
there has to be you know how long can
the skirt be how um must you wear a
skirt um do the does what the women wear
have to be a certain way and the men
wear a certain way um and so I'm
concerned about who's going to make uh
make those decisions and then who's
going to enforce them um
um which is not spelled out here so I'll
be voting against this as well thank
you Smith I have more faith than that I
think the idea is we do not want a
representative showing up for committee
or a house session wearing flipflops
board short and a and a wo hang forever
shirt that hasn't been washed since Co I
mean I think things where this rule
would arise are going to be pretty
obvious
I don't believe the intent is that um I
have to start shopping at Lord and
Taylor or Brooks Brothers I got this on
clearance for 50 bucks and I'm very
happy with
it I further believe that when there is
an issue it'll be glaringly obvious and
that the leaders of both caucuses in the
house will be able to have a talk so
that the member can be talk to and I I
don't think we're going to be looking at
skirt length unless it's a micro skirt
in which casee maybe we should but I
mean beyond
that I have faith in both sides being
out further
discussion Simpson
um having taught school sometimes I have
a little less Faith than you do
representative Smith um in how easily
this will be to work out so um I hope to
be included in conversations about how
we're going to operationalize this
today well I was not going to talk on
any of these but I I think on this one
um I mean I definitely agree
that along
with discipline and uh civility in the
house we
have gone downhill over the number of
past number of years and I would not in
any way
uh I'm looking at something that's
egregious which both sides have done in
the past three or four
years um you know
offensive t-shirts or things of that
nature that I've seen both sides wear or
um somebody coming in in Farmer jeans or
something like that I'm not going to uh
get involved in somebody that might come
in in a in a dress shirt and a jacket
and maybe have jeans on would that
probably not be proper attire yes but I
think you know we have to use common
sense here I think this is just a way
for us to stop the egregious stuff that
we've seen over the past few years and
yes representative Simpson I will
consult
you thank you
so uh there's no further discussion
motion is to adopt the N Amendment
represent Packard yes representative
Smith yes representative ducet yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson no representative
eel representative Weber no
representative Sullivan
no amendment is recommended 5
to4 the next is amendment to house rule
power thank you Mr Speaker and committee
members I appreciate the opportunity to
introduce to you today my proposed
amendment to house rule 39b for the
record I am representative Diane power I
represent the towns of Brookline Mason
in Greenville in Hillsboro County
District
36 so this proposed house rule is simple
and straightforward it requires that all
first drafts must be sent to the P to
the sponsor at least 10 days prior to
the sign off deadline for all lsrs in
rule
66 and the reason I'm proposing this is
in the past specifically last term I had
the unfortunate experience of not having
a 10day sign off period for um
some of my
lsrs so by by way of example I received
the first draft of one of my lsrs the
day before the sign off
deadline
and I saw the email the next day and
therefore I I had less than 24 hours to
review and to be able to sign off on
that LSR and as a result I I ended up
losing co-sponsors so what I seek to do
with this proposed house rule amendment
is to minimally require that all first
drafts have the opportunity for that
10day sign off
questions thank you for taking my
question um the um I agree with your
concern and with what's what's happening
oops may I respond so I I appreciate
that that um
observation um my thought with this is
that that this proposed house rule
change would help OS to prioritize their
workflow and that you know like I said
they should they it would be beneficial
if they were to be able to prioritize
first drafts first rather than maybe
working on redrafts
and the other comment that I would have
to um your observation is that with the
um I guess the what I call the rule 66
that deadline in
66 having extended time beyond that then
I believe would impact the ability for
the clerk and the speaker to go through
all the the bills and to be able to
assign them to committees so then you're
bumping up into another deadline
so I felt that this was the best way to
um deal with or address the
you I I guess I'll just say that I mean
I I think we all agree that there's a
appropriate or or even a workable
solution like how how can you force
someone to do something that they can't
physically
do I don't know but I also don't know
that extent uh granting a grace period
at at the end of the of um of the
deadline is workable either because then
then you set up an incentive to just not
do the work at all
until the last minute
do
Smith so I I think what they're getting
at
is the how do you enforce it how do you
tell the OS employees you now have 10
days less to do your work would you be
open to instead a simpler
change draft it in my head not not
withstanding the provisions of house
rule
39b all sponsors shall have a 10-day
sign off period on
lsrs like we still want them to get
their work done on time and there are
going to be exceptions to that and we
still want to have the 10
days and try to have the speaker work
with that staff to minimize the
occurrences this would come up in would
that work for
you thank you representative um I
appreciate that feedback I I'm will
willing to support whatever the
committee thinks is you know is best
that wouldn't be my my
preference but I appreciate um working
with the language that's here I I feel
that some solution um needs to be
proposed and like I stated before I feel
it's a it's a matter of
workflow in
OS and for the record I did discuss this
um does the house clerk have any
okay uh sorry weable yeah did you talk
about it with OS at all how they would
effectuate this thank you representative
um no I did not I and the reason I
didn't is because this is the first rule
change that I've ever proposed and um it
wasn't clear to me that that would be
something that that I would be able to
discussion okay representative Smith for
motion I move to not adopt the power
Amendment
second there viewable seconds
discussion l call roll motion before us
is to not adopt the power Amendment
represent Packard
no to not
adopt right to not adopt yes no
representa
Smith yes sir on the
motion representative duet yes
representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative eel yes representative
Weber yes representative Sullivan
misspoke chair votes yes thank
this is amendment to house
rule
Osborne yeah so um last spring we
engaged in a number of meetings between
Republican and Democrat uh leadership uh
discuss in various rule changes um
designed to speed up our work
um I get I would may use the phrase cut
to the chase so um we spend a lot of
time uh hearing bills and debating bills
that we all know what the eventual
outcome is going to be and we we do
these uh kind of year after year after
year so if uh there were ways that we
could all agree to kind of set those
issues aside and and focus more of our
attention on uh more pressing issues I
think that would be a benefit this is
the only amendment that's been brought
forward that that was discussed in those
meetings and this would uh uh create a
new concept called a
tabling calendar where uh three quarters
of a committee could vote to place a
bill on the table calendar uh without a
public
hearing and in order uh for that to be
sent back to the Committee for Public
hearing uh would require a simple
majority uh of the house to vote to do
expiring Senator
wber thank you and
I I was involved in those conversations
and initially thought that this was a
pretty promising
notion and I guess my question is I want
to explain explore a little more how the
process would go because while the
initial
referral makes sense I I like the three
quarters I like the concept of not
having to deal with stuff in committee
but I'm
thinking about various times when
members of a committee have been very
much on the same page and taken
something to the house only to find out
that the rest of the house wasn't even
reading the same book um and when that
happens um you've provided
for something to be removed from the
tabling calendar just as we remove it
from the consent
calendar and uh
recommitted to the committee for further
consideration but it might have passed a
deadline which is why provided it is not
passed the deadline and I think my
concern with with this is if the
majority of the house wants the thing
taken
up uh and we're past the deadline for
doing the committee
process uh then we're really real bind
and I think that the other thing is that
if it's removed from the tabling
calendar and we have debate on the floor
and a vote on the floor and then it goes
back to committee and it's scheduled for
hearing I think the potential
for actually using more of the body's
time with this procedure than with the
current procedure of perhaps simply
scheduling something for a very brief
hearing and then an immediate executive
session um is
is we're going to find that it's um
going to take up more than our other
time than than we had hoped it would
save so um that's my concern with the
formulation yeah just to respond so that
it could it certainly could be the case
that uh it takes some time um um maybe
the clerk can correct me if I'm wrong
but the the motion to remove a bill from
the table wouldn't be um
debatable if I'm if that's
um this is a new thing uh we would need
to establish whether that is a
debatable uh situation or not um I I
would I would contend um that it
wouldn't be only for the sheer fact that
two table or to remove from the table is
not a debatable
motion uh you could of course have
parliamentary inquiries uh but that that
that's my
rationale but may I ask a followup
question of the clerk question but that
is following a vote of the Full House to
lay something on the table or to removed
from the table this is uh putting
something on the table at the
recommendation of a single Committee of
the house uh without any debate and I
realize we can change all of our rules
at any time but uh one of the things
that I am concerned
about
is unbelievably irritating as some of
our debates are to me um removing all
possibility of debate of a bill from the
house is entirely against all of the
Traditions that have been in place since
I've been here and um when I discuss
them with other
places um I find
that the more that people say are you
out of your mind to do it that way the
more I um I value that we do it our way
irritating as it may be and the idea
that a a ma a super majority of a single
committee can
effectively um override the will of a
majority of a house or potentially is is
troubling to
me um and and again you know it didn't
go on the table as a vote of our
house um it it goes on a newly created
calendar um by a vote of committee and
those are two different things so I I
just have real concerns about the
process and the advisability of the
process just just to be clear my my
understanding would be um that the table
calendar to to adopt the recommendation
would need a vote similar to the consent
calendar so it would be a um a vote of
the house to put it on the table
well but presumably prior to that there
is the removal of something from the
calendar just as the the the chair
currently states are there any bills to
be removed from the consent calendar and
whether or not that would be debatable
is is the debatable question right now I
I think we could clarify that yeah uh
with language if you wanted to well my
suggestion would be not to do it but I I
I do note that clarifying that might be
helpful
but further discussion representative
Smith so I don't know maybe the clerk
can check me if for being correct or not
if we pass a deadline then you just make
a motion to suspend house rules and so
far as to allow the recommitment of the
bill right you can do that thank you and
further question Mr Speaker further
question
and really only matters in year two
right because in year one the committee
gets it back but it's too late to act
can't they just vote to
retain yes thank
you Senator Weber and the problem with
that is if it's something that needs
immediate action there's an issue and
if um you know what was contemplated
here was a majority of the
house acting on the bill and the
scenario that you are postulating
requires a super majority to be able to
recommit it so again you are taking away
the majority of the house if it is the
will of the majority but not a super
majority
Osborne right um yes uh so first of all
there's nothing's preventing the house
from acting
on the removal of these uh bills from
the uh tabling calendar um prior to the
deadline
there's we we meet multiple times before
um before the deadline expires right um
also so if uh it comes to be that this
process is more cumbersome than it's
worth to deal with we don't have to use
it
and and maybe uh and maybe we don't but
it is just a tool to add to the tool box
guess I would only say at this point
that we have been
talking about this for a not this
particular thing but ways to try and
streamline our process of the extreme
number of bills that we've been getting
year after
year and it's getting to the point where
um we're going to have trouble uh
retaining members we're going to have
trouble getting members to sit on a
committee and it's going to get more and
more difficult if we don't find some
ways to start reducing the number of
bills that every committee has to
hear uh and I think this is a way we we
discussed it quite a bit um you know
when we were meeting earlier and uh I I
just think it's worth giving it a try
and I still think there's other things
we have to look into and try and figure
out how we're going to uh uh stop the uh
excessive number of bills that we're
getting every year and I just feel that
this is a at least one one first step if
it doesn't work we can we can get rid of
it but I think it's worth a
try
yes I guess I might be a little bit
confused um this talks about um the
committee placing it on the U table
calendar um by a 3/4 vote does that
table calendar then get voted on by the
entire house because I don't see that
here it does not say that the table
calendar must be approved by a majority
uh well uh yes that's that's the
intention I guess it would just suggest
view uh Mr clerk do you have a uh yes Mr
uh Mr Speaker I I Mr chairman I would
suggest that the the way this was
crafted uh is intending to mirror the
language of the consent calendar and and
and that it is um it is mirrored
essentially the same way we're not we're
not um we're not talking about doing a
different a different mechanism um again
if if if it would be better clarified we
change further
discussion Z Smith for a
motion I move to accept the Osborne
there a
roll Mr Mr chairman could I just take
one quick second just to um to laay
representative uh Sullivan's concerns
the current house rule 52 which does
discuss the consent calendar um does not
not specifically address that when we
talk about the order of business uh we
talk about the uh adoption of the
consent calendar so uh that's that's
clarification sorry the question is on
Amendment representative Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes yes
representative Simpson no represent eel
represent Weber no represent Sullivan
no amendment is recommended 5 to
four move on to Amendment house rule 43
Smith thank you Mr Speaker a yield to
the
clerk uh thank you Mr chairman um
thank you representative Smith try to
fake the sincerity at least the um this
is this is a a a change that I had
proposed to representative Smith all it
does is um uh basically put into uh
reality what our practice has been for
the last several years we used to hand
out gray
folders um and and which was a a um
which basically had a staple of the bill
inside of it and which uh was kept in
the committee drawers here in the
Legislative Office Building uh they were
docketed by the clerk's teams and um
eventually destroyed by the office of
legislative Services um and several
years ago our practice uh became such
that um we essentially just said uh the
Chairman's copy would be a copy of the
bill uh just as every member received a
copy of the bill um and this this is
really just a housekeeping amendment to
to just say that after each bill has
been numbered uh we'll procure a
sufficient number of copies we don't we
don't need to um we I I have boxes and
boxes of these gray folders that that
have uh Fallen by the wayside but this
was a um this was a uh discussion
between uh committee Services um the
Senate clerk's office my office many
years ago uh and that's why that process
has changed so we uh we were just
suggesting a quick update to
housekeeping
is there any discussion
tell uh representative Smith for a
Amendment
okay I I move amendment to house rule 43
okay
second second representative second the
motion before us is to approve amendment
to house rule 43 is there any further
roll
yes representative Smith yes
representative duet yes representative
Osborne yes representative Sweeney yes
representative sibson yes representative
eel representative Weber yes represent
suan
yes amendment is recommended 9 to
Z the next is amendment to house rule
100 proposed by representative Dan
sorry thank you Mr Speaker I'm
representative Alvin C from marac County
District 26 which is iial District which
includes lden and seven other
towns U this particular rule change is
uh intended
to
um um ensure that uh when the house is
asked to vote to concur or non-c concur
on a on a bill that's returned from the
Senate that uh it's been considered
carefully because once we take a uh a
vote on that
uh the bill either goes straight to the
governor or
goes uh into the dust bin of History
without any uh further recourse so uh
the idea here is that uh 20 sets of eyes
would be preferable to just one or two
sets of eyes looking at any particular
bill that was returned to us
um this bill allows for the uh chairman
to recommend the committee of conference
because we do get another bite at the
Apple uh after a committee of
conference uh
also on occasion the uh the other body
puts in uh amendments that we might
consider non gerain even if they don't
concern them so um such that if not
carefully noticed might allow something
to pass that maybe should have been uh
considered more carefully or possibly by
a different policy
committee um because it might have been
something that we would consider a
different committee's action the uh
impetus for me to uh put this in was uh
early this spring we had House Bill 154
which the senate had taken a bill from
uh Municipal and County of uh
government and amended it to be a um
election law Bill a 32p part bill for
election law and when it came to the
floor for a vote there was uh actually
ended up being two different motions one
to Concur and one to uh ask for a
committee of conference from two
different committee chairs so that was a
little confusing we ended up voting to
Concur and it was presented to us as
strictly house keeping although I think
it looked more complicated than just
housekeeping uh therefore I hope this
rule addition will be able to uh provide
more clarity and be reinsuring to the
members that uh any bill that's come
from the Senate return from the Senate
has uh been carefully looked at before
we get a
you
discussion representative Smith
thank you so just so I'm
clear this passes chairs can no longer
concur non-c concur without having a
vote of the committee that would that
would be the intent follow up for
question all right so in a case which
happens all the time where there's
something we want really badly from the
Senate and we make a deal we say okay
look you need to do this you hold up
your your end will concur with this you
don't want that to happen
anymore I don't know the circumstance is
of any hypothetical so um and I haven't
been involved in a situation like that
so I don't know the answer to
that although question one more yeah so
um let me try to explain it better
because it happens all the time um I'll
go with a not recent
example we had made an agreement with
Senate transportation that they were
going to concur with something and
exchange there was something we didn't
particularly care about but I let them
them think we did so we were going to
hold that up if we didn't get what the
house wanted from them deals done on the
day of voting on those Committee of
conference
reports the um the Senate ended up not
holding up their end it failed on the
floor I had about 7 minutes to make a
decision walk back to the house floor
and decide to non-c concur to let them
know that we were
serious you would prefer that I ask for
a house recess convene my committee for
a vote I mean I don't understand how
this is going to
work okay I was not uh fully aware of
the behind the scenes dealings that
might
occur um but I was very concerned
about bills coming to the house the Full
House and we're suddenly told by a
committee chair yes we vote Yes on this
or no on this one and not giving much of
a reason and it's not been very clear so
I just found that um that part that
discussion
Stringham yes uh thank you so I just
wanted to there is a timing thing that's
that's a it's a possible problem with
this idea because we're talking about
bills right at the very end right at the
very end of the session um but it seems
to me it's not that bad right we we
sometimes have uh lunchtime
announcements or end of the day
announcements where a chair will say my
committee is going to meet for exec
session following this session or during
lunch and and they have a quick exec
session on a bill so it is quite
possible to uh to squeeze things in in
in that sense right so um I I don't know
about your seven minute example right
but but in general you know this can be
so any comments question yeah I I just I
just uh I have the same same basic view
that uh in particular uh concern is when
uh there's been any kind of significant
uh change that uh that may lead to
another policy committee needing to look
at something that uh just
having uh having a reasonable uh
discussion with the committee uh before
moving forward um Can can prevent a
major mistake so that's a one of the
discussion
okay
Smith I move to not adopt uh C Maguire
Stringham
Amendment here a
second second General wbor seconds
J
Weber this is another one of these
things that in theory I'm very much in
favor of um and in fact
when because this is the only time I've
been privy to these discussions uh under
the speakers that were Democratic Speers
that I served under which is all of them
um there was always a
policy expressed by the speaker to the
committee chairs which was that the
committee chairs were going to poll
their members on concurrences or non-c
concurrences and that happened
informally um and often at the last
minute and and um and I actually think
that was a good thing I
think so in that respect I'm for this um
I do do want to just recognize though
that uh as this is written it doesn't
deal with the problems of the bills to
which other bills have been attached
which drive all of us fairly crazy
because it goes back to the original
committee and whether or not it has any
of the original
committee's content on it or
not um and
and that's not very helpful um so in in
many ways I would hope that the speaker
would establish a policy that says that
members of all the Committees involved
get at least
um I admit that this is another one of
those things that's a troubling piece of
so just be just um see you know webs and
that has been my uh direction to the
Committees is that they do everything in
their power to try and make sure that
the committee members especially you
know the ranking member is notified and
spoken to before any decision is made
and that has been standing but as
representative Smith points out
sometimes that's not possible so uh I I
think that's why
this this is a little troubling for
those circumstances where we have to get
our business done and this could uh
hinder us a little bit in in doing that
but uh that has been my direction to
committees uh right along is that they
uh do everything in their power to make
sure that the Committees and especially
like I said the ranking memb is uh is uh
okay I think we have a motion
right there's no further discussion
Court will read the uh read the the
motion is to uh not
accept representative Packard no yes on
the motion not to yeah representative
Smith yes representative duet yes
represent Osborne yes represent Sweeney
yes represent Simpson yes represent yes
represent Weber yes represent Sullivan
Z uh this is amendment to house rule
number
10 uh proposed by representative Maguire
and
stringle all
right I was about to do the other one so
let
me okay
uh yes thank you uh Mr Speaker
so uh this this is just something that's
a
that's a matter of of style or um taste
or something like that um we in debate
are are forbidden by Masons for of
mentioning the senate or the governor in
our debate right so so people get around
it by saying people through the wall or
the other body or the whatever and and
it's awkward and so um the purpose of
this rules amendment is to allow th
those discussions and debate um
now and it's really I don't know just to
me the rule as it currently exists is a
is a limitation on
speech and and it just it it feels
uncomfortable it it's just I I've never
seen the point of it it's important to
legislation um I mean either at the end
of the day a bill is either going to
become law or it's not right and so the
entire process of legislation is
something of Interest right not just
that what the house wants to do but what
the entire legislature and Governor want
to do with a particular piece of piece
of legislation and so
um and especially when you're
considering amendments or maybe floor
amendments and that kind of thing they
might have relevance to what's going to
happen to a bill down the line so um
that's the main point of this is just to
allow people to
discuss um discussions they've had with
senators or Governor or whatever as part
of their debate and you know I can see
how this is not to everybody's taste I
mean
I know the our clerk is not in favor of
this because it's something that's um
you know essentially Universal right I
mean no other state as far as we know
does this and so on um
but just in the interest of of freeing
up our speech I think we can try it if
turns out it's not you know it's not
that great two years from now you can
change it right so um anyway yeah thanks
you know for for me this is a matter of
decorum and respect uh I respect the
Senate I respect the governor but I
respect the people who put a lot of time
into preparing uh to inform us about a
specific issue and ask for our support
and a vote and so many times it seems
like uh in the middle of making a point
um the think become awkward and they
have to talk about the other body and uh
you kind of get away from the point
they're trying to make while you're
sitting there concentrating and um uh
you know realizing how much time and
effort theyve put into this just the the
use of a non- dirty word in fact a
wonderful word like Senate uh you know
sh should be allowed in our great body
uh you know provided all the uh other
rules of of decorum and respect were
followed and I see no reason to uh to
Blacklist that word um uh as part of
debate in any format so that's why I
supported and work with representative
Maguire on this and bring this to you
thank you for your consideration and
thank you all for working here today by
Weber just as a point of the Byzantine
nature of our rules uh what is the point
of re
of
um making an exception for one part of
Masons which would then change our
debate without
also addressing the issue that our
custom usage in precedent is a higher
order of authority in our rules than is
Mason's Mason is below our custom usage
in president which has for forever been
not to utter the words and to use a
separate
location and my second question is if
you put all that time and effort into an
argument can you not when you write it
out the first time write it out with the
other side of the wall or um some other
location that might let people know what
you're talking about let me answer the
second question first which
is to me reading this in
Masons using the other side of the wall
and all that sort of stuff that is sort
of prohibitive you see what I mean it's
talking about the other body that's that
what is what um it's not the word so
much as it is the concept right it's
it's like you know we're self-contained
we should have our own opinions and so
on
versus what's happening outside in that
sense so so I would tend to think I mean
in general we let people do that but but
I think that's against the spirit of the
rule now your first question about the
way this is drafted I'm going to defer
to the clerk who helped us with it
so I I don't have a good answer for
that uh just to for clarity Mr Speaker
um custom usage in precedent does uh
come above our parliamentary guide um
however the Parliamentary guide um
specifically Mason's manual has been our
parliamentary guide uh since about the
50s um and the reason um in in terms of
of debate specifically uh where the
guide is specific and custom usage in
precedent has involved has in has
evolved to include that uh if you accept
the the the provision of the manual
that's that's where that custom has has
evolved from um so I I as as the member
uh from Epsom said uh I I did advise uh
against this in general uh because of
the um the sort of universally accepted
um provision that we don't talk about
the executive or the other branch of the
of the legislature um but I but in in
terms of uh uh the very specifics of of
custom usage in precedent I I I don't
discussion okay yeah represent Smith
thank
you I hate people on the other side of
the wall it's a euphemism and I'd be
very happy if we started geling people
for that I don't know may maybe people
disagree but I see the point of the rule
as we should focus on our own work and
not worry about what everyone else is
doing and produce the distilled position
of the house that's not the end of the
process right then it goes to the Senate
what if they don't like it I don't care
if they don't like it while I'm building
it once it gets there now I care deeply
and that's why sponsors should follow
their bills committees should follow the
committee chairs should follow their
bills on the other side and that's what
amendments are for that's what
committees have conf Es are for that's
why invested Representatives who think
there might be a problem with the
governor should then be reaching out to
the governor none of that should be used
to convince me I just want to know if
the Bill's a good idea in the house or
not so I don't know I support what we do
now and I'd actually like to see it
comment Smith for motion
I move to not adopt the Maguire
Stringham amendment to house rule to
Second it's been moved and seconded is
discussion okay with that the clerical
call a rooll the question is to excuse
me not not recommend represent Packard
yes representative Smith yes
representative duet
yes representative Osborne yes represent
Sweeney yes represent Simpson yes
represent eel yes represent Weber yes
represent Sullivan
90 the next is amendment to house rule
47f uh proposed by Representatives Dan
Maguire and
Stringham thank you Mr Speaker so this
one is has some similarity to uh the C
Amendment but it's uh it's for an
earlier um situation which is when a
when a bill is destined to go to a
second committee the chair of that
committee currently has the power to
Simply wave the bill away and if they do
that then the bill would go in its
current form over to the Senate um and
or or if it's a Senate bill it would go
then um I guess to the governor right
because or or back to the senate for
deciding if they're going to do a
committee of conference or not so in any
case it's it's for cases where a bill is
scheduled to go to a second committee
but the second committee's chair doesn't
want to deal with it okay and uh both of
us are members of the finance committee
so we get this situation all the time
that that a lot of bills come to us as a
second committee and
um this is simply that we don't want
mistakes made right right and and
whenever there's sort of one person
who's
um who's the definitive person on what
happens to a bill that person you know
inadvertently can make a mistake whereas
if a whole committee makes a decision
there's much less chance that something
is going to be
overlooked um we had a situation like
that last time I I won't necessarily get
into it but um it's just a matter
of um let's have uh more people think
about a bill um than just one person and
especially when when there this is not a
situation where there's a house vote
after they make this decision because
after they make this decision it's gone
right it's it's it's the end of the line
for that bill um and uh so it's it's
really as simple as
that yeah
largely uh have follow the same same uh
line uh you know will say there was a
case where my understanding is that an
original Bill did not have a lot of uh
Financial consequences to it it was
waved off second committee uh uh even
and as soon as that's done it's in the
Senate uh Finance never got to address
it and had Fairly significant
implications to the budget wouldn't have
been hard to uh have a uh a polling of
Finance in that case um seems to me um
committee chairs uh work hard to get a
good committee with them it's worth
worth getting the input and uh uh
respecting the process uh to get it
right uh and uh still with reasonable
timetables so um in terms of waving off
second committee bills um uh this is one
that two of us were planning to bring
forward uh to you all regardless of of
which uh party was in control uh that we
felt uh that a mistake had been made uh
last term and uh this was a reasonable
remedy so I hope hope you'll uh go
you questions from Weber I would just
say that I'm I'm very much in favor of
this one simply because
um I think we've all had the situation
where um bills have real implications
for several committees and uh for
example um you know some of the Health
and Human Services committee bills go to
other cons committees and we have
thought that there would be a robust
discussion of whatever the other issues
were in another committee only to find
that that committee chair has uh waved
the bill off and it it it's not always
Finance although it's often Finance
because they're the most usual second
committee but uh I'm thinking of any
number of our bills that go to Edna or
other committees where our assumption on
the policy committee is we don't have to
deal with that because it's not our area
of
expertise and it's uh not something that
we want to spend a lot of our time on
because we may get it horribly wrong and
then to have only one member of the next
committee get to make that decision is
sometimes
discouraging so I would I would urge
represent
smth I move to not adopt the Maguire
47f
second been moved and seconded further
discussion Senator
Smith there are always one-offs I just
don't believe that this has
risen as a problem to the level that we
need to take away tools of chairman one
the cases where we have to move
fast you you wave it off it's still
going to go to the Senate you can still
amend the thing if you're still not
happy you can still request a committee
of conference you can non-c concur it's
not like it's the end of the process
there so I don't support
this further discussion s
Simpson thank you Mr chair um I am
actually thinking about the timing as
well and think that this doesn't have
the same timing problem as the previous
Amendment because it would be before
um it would this would have to happen
before the second committee deadline so
it shouldn't have the same issue as the
other one did so I will be
thank represent
Weber and I think that you know I'm just
going to
beat a dead horse a little bit and say
oh great you know we don't want to talk
about what the Senate does but we want
to leave what the Senate does we want to
Omit a whole layer of house
input and send it direct to the Senate
with the hope that the Senate will do it
right and as we all know the Senate is
not as good as we are at
looking very care carefully at um the
granular layers of things um so I I
think that anytime we ensure that both
of the Committees get a look is good and
I certainly have
seen
occasionally a time when I think that
the
um declining of a bill has been used on
a very political basis so
um I'm I'm I'm in favor of the two
committee referrals and I think we
should uh depart from that in very very
few circumstances because there's a
looks reble thank you um Mr Speaker Mr
chair um I'm gonna vote against the
motion because I support this but if the
which I assume if the motion
passes I hope at some level maybe the
speaker could encourage committee chairs
to get the input of their committees in
the decision on whether or not to wave a
um I didn't want to interrupt okay um I
um completely agree with with the
representative eel I think that um I can
instruct when we have our Chairman's
training to uh make sure that they do
they do every effort to make sure that
they uh contact the rest of the
committee and again especially the
ranking member to make sure that uh
they're not doing something that the
full committee would be against but I I
hate to take
away the tools of a uh of a chairman um
in a situation that might only exist
twice was one may I ask the clerk a
question yeah about how this would work
so um so we meet on
Thursday bill is voted
on uh the second committee decides to
meet on Friday to vote on whether
to um decline so what happens to that
bill at that point does it go directly
to the senate or does it have to come
back to the body to
be again thank you for the question um
so what happens currently is when a bill
is sent to a second committee um and it
is referred uh there um the bill stays
in our possession uh if I receive
notification that the chair has waved
the second committee referral um that
notice gets read on the floor at the
next session date and the bill goes on
the third reading list for that date um
and that it is then at the end of that
next session date transmitted to the
other
body just the followup and it would be
on that day then it would be available
for reconsideration motion for example
so no
because when it has been assigned to a
second committee it is no longer in the
possession of the
house it is in the possession of the
committee so that's why sometimes when
when you see uh the speaker um on the
floor address a bill having been sent to
a second committee and a member will
jump up and instantly move
reconsideration the me the motion's not
in order because the bill is therefore
not in the possession of the house
anymore is in the possession of the
committee when the bill um
when the bill is back so to speak and
that the the chair has waved the
referral of the second committee it is
put on the third reading list in theory
um you could do something with it but
then again we have a bigger problem
because of notice of
reconsideration um and uh we're getting
into an area where I'm not really
comfortable giving you an answer without
giving you uh more time reason this is
Weber argue that it is workable
because um the issues of notice and and
reconsideration are very valid ones so
that part is could be an issue but
unlike the other discussions that we
have had
where
it's important that something happened
very quickly and our deadlines
forbid whatever the next thing that we
were offering to have happen
happen the
motion the the declining of the referral
of the bill has to
[Music]
come at least I often it happens
immediately like 10 minutes after the
house is voted um and the clerk has
reminded me that no I can't get up and
ask for reconsideration because it's not
in the possession of the house because
I've made that mistake a number of times
uh
but because these the the bill has to
have been acted on by the house in the
first instance before the deadline and
we have the whole rest of the time for
the bill to be acted on by the second
committee which is built into our
schedule there is time to have this
discussion with the committee if our
rules require it so um I don't see the
possibility of
um I don't see the possibility of it
interfering with our work I do see the
possibility uh and I think that
representative Osborne has outlined it
quite well of how things can go wrong if
if the committee chair gets it wrong and
we we can't as a as a committee or as
discussion
Smith thank you um okay so the committee
votes that they're going to wave off on
the bill is it now a bill not in a
let's say it only add two it goes
someplace and then Finance Finance waves
off the committee votes yes we're going
to wave off is it now a one committee
bill I mean the the situation is that
the yes it's it's no longer a
a two committee bill in the sense that
that the committee has waved off um it
was assigned that way uh at the
beginning of the process all bills when
they are assigned are assigned at the
beginning uh as to when it's going
whether it will be a second committee
bill or not okay follow up question so
thank you
so one committee or not if it goes to
that process it is always a bill going
to a second committee whether it is or
not as far as deadlines go correct all
bills all bills that are second
committee bills are designated as early
bills
questions there have none per will call
a roll the question is to not adopt the
Maguire 47f Amendment represent Packard
yes represent Smith yes representative
ducet yes representative Osborne yes
represent Sweeney yes representative
Simpson no representative eel no
representative Weber no representative
Sullivan no motion to not recommend is
four the amendment next is the amendment
to house rule 50F proposed by
representative Stringham and
representative Carol
Maguire uh thank you very much uh um
representing this bill this this um uh
rule request is is really about uh
respect and deorum uh I very much
appreciate your comment about uh wanting
to motivate uh people to be in the
legislature uh and work hard and uh um
you know see see uh fruits from what
they do uh the
circumstance of this rule change it's a
very difficult one uh to um uh put
together a a request change uh to
totally modify it because uh the reason
deals with the committee of conference
and uh the reasons uh that we want
unanimity out of the committee of
conference are very very
good uh so the circumstances here uh is
that um uh um is uh one member uh is
assigned to the committee of conference
um uh quickly agrees to maybe house or
Senate version uh of of a bill that's
been worked on in the case uh one that I
worked on I wasn't the prime sponsor was
actually somebody from the other party
who we worked very hard uh first uh
introducing in the house getting through
the house getting through the Senate a
minor change in the Senate uh went to
Committee of conference at the uh um
close to the last minute um one member
was changed um the committee of
conference was very short uh the sign
off uh uh came out uh and the the one
individual just never signed off on it
um and that it's a circumstance of I
guess you call it a parliamentary
maneuver uh but you know in terms of
what it means for the people who work on
the bill they work on writing it they uh
certainly the case for me I was uh I
testified when it was introduced into a
house committee not my committee um and
uh followed it to the Senate also spoke
uh at its introduction in the Senate uh
passed both both Chambers with strong
bipartisan majority almost three
quarters and the um uh uh the final
disposition out of Committee of
conference uh is just no sign off uh
there's there was nothing in the
committee of conference to indicate that
uh what the reason was uh and why uh
this fruitless work
uh should have progressed that way and I
don't think that's good uh respect for
for our members uh efforts uh I don't
think it's proper decorum uh and I I
think there's only C certain
circumstances where we can do something
about it uh the purpose of this rule
change is to you know if we get to a
committee of conference and uh the
agreement
between uh all the all the members is uh
to accept you know you know the house or
Senate
version um and everybody agrees then
that gives the chairman the ability to
to sign off on it because there's no uh
I you know I don't think we can delay it
if there's going to be rewrites even
though Committee of conference normally
is to accept one version or the other
sometimes there's a compromise between
the
two so um I both wanted to um you know
Express um you know what what some of
the my concerns are about using that
kind of a maneuver in general uh but
also you know suggest that under certain
circumstances you know if if uh there's
good reasons um you know i' I've gone to
I've been on Committee of conference or
and had only one person object and they
tell me their reasons they're they're
empowered to do it I respect that and I
appreciate appreciate knowing and I feel
like uh the time the time that the
representatives the legislators put into
it are well spent and um uh you know
worth worth coming coming back to get
beat up again on so uh that's what this
this rule change um is meant to do is it
at least provide some
circumstances uh where um um where an an
objecting member of a committee of
conference would have uh you know the be
given the courtesy to say in front of
everybody what what exactly the uh the
reasons are perhaps they could be talked
out of it perhaps
so discussion representative Smith thank
you so in the rule change does chair
confires
yes um follow question y so right now
the leaders of both caucuses can sign
off for any of their members it sounds
like in this case somebody failed to do
that because of that you don't think we
should encourage them to use the process
and instead have rules
change I'm I'm fuzzy on that I mean we
can already sign off for anybody matter
of fact if somebody decides in bad faith
to hose the process and isn't going to
sign the speaker is free to replace them
put someone else on and have them sign
so yeah I you know I think the
circumstances when this happens is
usually uh the individual and and
whoever is representing the speaker
probably both agree uh to not sign off
on the bill and and I believe um and uh
in speaking with um uh Carol Maguire who
also um was part of this uh rule change
amendment process too is is that uh
under you know extreme circumstances
this is a strategy uh to you know uh end
the life of the bill so and as a speaker
working together with a person who's um
or acting speaker uh with the person is
in the committee and it doesn't stop
them from doing that but it it does
provide a uh an environment where at
least everybody who's in there can hear
what the reasons
you further discussion in
avable well all I was going to say is
that um at Committees of conference many
times it's a you know a verbal
discussion and there is consensus at the
committee of conference that X Y and Z
have been agreed upon and um it's not
always the case even though there may be
good will it's not or probably is
Goodwill uh it may always it's not
always the case that what is in the
written word is an a correct um
reflection of what the discussion was in
the opinion of the person that is a
conferee that would be signing and I
think in some respect this takes away
the um the opportunity and the right of
the conferee to read and agree with the
context I mean if they ultimately don't
agree obviously they could be replaced
or whatever but um maybe it's the lawyer
in me but I don't always have faith that
things are written down exactly the way
they're um agreed whether intentionally
or not and so that's why I would
struggle to support this I understand
repr senat
Weber I I'm mostly seconding what
representative eel said but I think
given your stated aims one of the issues
might be the signature but I don't think
the signature is the real problem um the
speaker can either for very respectable
means when you have a Committee Member
who is acting in bad faith replace the
Committee Member the speaker can also if
they choose to do so torpedo something
by removing a Committee Member and
appointing somebody won't won't sign so
that goes either way and this does
nothing to address that but I think the
overriding concern and and one that I
know is a matter of great discussion
among our caucus members is if you serve
on a committee of conference it is
absolutely your duty to read and now of
course everything's online so you can do
that without having to drive all the way
to conquer and get your phisical
signature you you can read the bill
online and direct either somebody in
your uh party or somebody in the
speaker's office to do the signature but
I think having that check that more than
one set of eyes has got to take a good
look at the bill is really important and
I don't think as
drafted this measure really
addresses the problem that you're
concerned about and I think there are a
lot of things to be concerned about with
the committee of conference process I
just haven't figured out a way to get
through that
particular set of issues that does it
better um with all the frustrations that
I think all of us have with it so um I I
too am am not in favor of this
formulation but thank you for raising
the issue further
discussion and Smith for a motion
I move to not adopt the string of
Maguire amendment to house rule 50F
there a second seconded is there any
further
discussion if not the clerk will call a
rooll the motion on the floor is to not
adopt representative Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative eel yes represent Weber
yes representative Sullivan
yes a recommendation is adopted 9 to
Z next we have amendment to house rule
Thomas thank
you thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
members of The Rules Committee for
taking a look at my proposal I think
that everyone here would agree that
there is um Credence in names uh on how
how how you you uh you know name things
and I think in the in the case of our uh
committee I think everyone would agree
that energy has been in the Forefront of
the news for many many years
internationally nationally uh the even
in the New Hampshire gubernatorial
elections energy has been at the
Forefront of a lot of um discussions so
uh my proposal to make a modest change
to the name of our committee to change
it to the to the the committee on energy
Science and Technology I think
recognizes the importance and the
Credence that this committee would would
be focusing on and has been focusing on
for several years uh for instance um
ever since uh my first term uh we have
had many bills that are energy related
and the exponential increase in the
number of them in proportion to our bus
bills in total has increased is is quite
evident uh in fact uh if I look at the
lsrs for coming up this year um I
predict that approximately of the 40
bills that are likely to come to my
committee give or take 37 of them are
energy or energy related including the
cost of electricity uh type of bills
that are foremost in our our news every
single year so I believe by putting the
word energy first in in our committee uh
shows U the people shows the rest of the
country that our committee is focused on
energy uh in in our committee as being
one of the foremost uh issues that we
face of our times here and I think and
for some time I think uh the Senate has
recognized that because their name is
the committee on energy and natural
resources and in fact if you look at the
committee description as it is even now
the word energy comes first in in the
description so it kind of makes sense at
this time that we that we put energy
first I've conferred with several
members on this issue and you know they
they said it it makes sense the chair my
good friend from eeping uh is totally
behind this change and my good friend
from Hollis who is likely to be the
ranking member is also not opposed to it
uh this proposal thinks it's it's a good
idea so I think it's time that we do to
make this change and I hope the rules
committee agrees that we can change our
name to put more emphasis on what we
really do on a on a day-to-day basis
here thank
you Senator
Weber thank you and I thank you for that
explanation
because um it highlights the assumption
that I made when I read this which was
that um there has always been a concern
for the Committees on the back end of
the alphabet that
perhaps they do get you know their bills
heard at the end of the day when things
are uh tired and grumpy and um I had
assumed that this was an effort to get
the very complicated and complex issues
heard by the committee moved forward in
and your explanation is very clear and I
have no objection to changing that on
that term but I am very concerned that
we are going to hear requests from
various other committees and I you know
Ways and Means comes to mind as to a
name change that would not keep them at
the end of the calendar and I'm already
wondering if Affairs of the elderly and
health and human services might be a
good way to go for the committee on
which I've been privileged to serve uh
so I don't have any objection in per se
in changing the name of the committee
but I would ask the speaker and I think
there's already been conversation about
this and I know that speaker narelli
made it a regular
practice uh to start with different
places in the calendar when the calendar
is written and when it's sent to the me
Members so that we know that that um
this this week instead of starting with
a we're going to start a quarter of the
way through the alphabet next week we're
going to start 2third of the way through
the alphabet and and the next week we're
going to start at the end of the
alphabet I hope that that rotation would
be adopted whatever we do with this rule
because I'm I'm concerned otherwise that
the perception will be um and and maybe
I got got hold of the entire wrong end
of the stick but I know that I was not
the only person who had this perception
was that the the real purpose is is a
more favorable place in the calendar and
I think that all of us ought to serve in
the rotation of those that get to
present our bills first and and who have
to wait later on so that's just my
thought on the whole thing well I um I
agree with you that the perception could
be that way in fact it it turns out to
be a it would be a a happy coincidence
in many situations where it would put us
further up in the calendar however as I
looked more into it I really started
thinking that the way it's written now
it almost puts energy as an afterthought
in our committee and it's not uh energy
is first and foremost in our community
we we spend 90 over 90% of our time
working on energy bills and I think that
if this was uh you know explained to
people in the way that I'm explaining it
now I think many people would understand
that the name of something does have
importance and by putting the word
energy in front of of this committee's
name tells people that we are the
committee of energy and Science and
Technology but energy has been at the
foremost of all of our bills almost osly
slow so uh over the years and and I
think the real impetus is that it we
should recognize that fact by making a
name change that properly and
importantly reflects what this committee
currently is you know does thank you for
the
explanation
intentions sorry that's that's just it's
not appropriate for any committee but I
do want to ask though is this isn't free
did you figure out um in proposing this
what the cost and effort and money is
going to be license plate design
business cards plaes on the wall
Weatherhead um website updates all of
that well no uh I I figured the license
plates haven't been done yet so perhaps
uh that change would be made prior to
any expense I did look at the fact that
many rsas do refer to the committee of
science techn energy my thought process
on that was since the name change is
merely a reversal of words and not any
significant change in the name itself
that any current RSA could not mistake
what the committee is whether it's
Science Tech energy or energy Science
and Tech uh it it would it would mean
the same thing and as we go forward in
life uh as some rsas make changes they
can they can certainly do some
housekeeping changes to uh clean up that
end of it but I I I did think in terms
of the rsas whether a report has to be
given to the chair of the Science Tech
SC science technology and energy chair
or to the chair of the energy Science
and Technology I don't think there would
be any mistake in in where it has to go
to in that respect so I don't think
there's any room for confusion on that
end Mr clerk thank you Mr Speaker just a
couple of points of clarification
regarding representative Smith's
question this change would not be acted
on until the 8th of January all
legislation will have been introduced at
that point so all bills for this year
will say science technology and energy
um all uh all records thereof will say
that this will this is
prospective uh amendments are just to
rules are just like laws they are not
retrospective uh so um in order to um it
would affect the second year of the
session in terms of what's appearing on
legislation uh for what what bills are
signed to
this committee um so really this will
not change and and and historically
license plates will have been handed out
at that point as well um so uh that is
what it is but um just for clarity um
this is this would affect going forward
after January 8th and so there are some
implications specific to legislation uh
bills that are being drafted right now
that may have uh Science Tech and energy
written in the bills with
uh need to be amended um if if the name
clarity bble and just following along
with what representative Smith said and
what you said I imagine there are
statutes at this point that refer to the
committee at this point in this way as
well so but I do also really believe
that there's going to start to be
competition among the Committees for
changing their name so they get further
discussion
motion I move to table the amendment to
house rule 30 the Thomas amendment to
31 we're not allowed to what
now can't do
know well in that case I move to not
recommend the Thomas amendment to house
rule
31 I'll make the
motion I'm good I'm the da I'll explain
that
question clerical caller roll the the
question is on to not adopt
representative Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative eel I'm sorry
representative Simpson yes
representative eel yes representative
Weber yes representative solivan yes
Mr Speaker or Mr chairman uh two points
under other
business um Mr Mr chairman um through a
miscommunication uh I had worked with
representative Reed on a few amendments
to house rules uh she was here earlier
uh in discussion with her yesterday I
misunderstood uh her intention of
whether or not those would be presented
today or on the 8th of January um and I
got it wrong uh she was here earlier to
discuss those um and she had to leave
for work and uh I am sorry for that I
messed that up it is it is completely on
me and I apologize uh to the committee
uh for that
um the second uh item is in discussion
uh regarding the Osborne Amendment um
and when uh I was speaking uh addressing
representative Sullivan's concerns uh
pursuant to the current rule 52 about
the voting um I realized uh in looking
at the amendment from representative
Osborne that I
missed um in house rule
58 the order of business uh Edition
where it currently
States um the orders of how we operate
and number eight is consideration of
consent calendar items number nine is
report from standing and select
committees um so uh representative
Osborne I will draft a floor Amendment
um unless the committee uh would be
interested in in allowing that but
that's entirely up to you um to
basically uh have a consideration of the
table calendar items as well um because
and again that is that is my fault and
and I apologize to the committee for
one you're an amendment yeah I'm fine
so is
um is representative Reed going to
present her amendments on as a floorman
I I will work with her to make sure that
8th is there any other business to come
uh Mr chairman just checking with the
requests I I believe this I believe the
speaker's notice indicated that they
needed to be um that the that they
needed to be on the agenda uh from
requests what is the committee I will I
will take a vote of the committee you
them Mr chairman you should probably
call them up individually to see what
they want to do and why yeah I just
wanted to make sure we could move
forward and it seems like the committee
is all right with moving forward for
accepting the Motions
uh considering not AC
yeah thank you Mr chairman excuse me
thank you Mr chairman and committee uh
in just of disclosure I I did go to uh
the appropriate office and was advised
that I was on the agenda and apparently
just didn't get on the agenda so I just
want you to know I like to follow
protocol and the and the rules on for
this special request uh that being said
uh specifically um uh the name is uh rep
Charles McMahon I'm out of District 17
wiam and I'm coming with a uh late um
filing request uh because I had an an
issue familywise take place I been an
ICU with my son for the last five and a
half six weeks and the uh I missed a
deadline U because of that and so I'm
just seeing if there's an opportunity
you might consider this the the bill
that I wanted to bring to the table was
dealing with um Elder exemptions from
property tax and
specifically uh I've done lot of lot of
work on this is to keep people in their
homes and its Elders in their homes uh
and the number of ideas and talking with
constituents um they came up and wanted
to been doing the research on this and
have a bill to present to the um to the
house uh on um incentivizing folks to
stay their homes by having an adjustment
on their property tax specific to the
school portion of the property tax and
what we're finding out uh uh out in the
cases to legitimize and hope hopefully
support these type of efforts is to have
a substantial enough benefit that the um
aggressively mature not old as I say but
over 65 can stay in their homes by
having a um an
obligation not credited but uh set aside
while they own their home and for uh 25
years uh you know 65 plus there's other
criteria but not means-based what uh so
there's other other issues that that I
can answer if you'd like now but wanted
that opportunity knowing that we have a
a clear housing crisis in affordable not
just affordable housing it's access for
elderly housing and apartments and town
homes as you know there's some some
Innovative credit issues going on but
it's based on income and uh there many
uh that that will be that's another
challenge so I wanted to bring this to
the table with timing being of the
essence uh but I I I come again with the
apology that this I should have been
done earlier but that was the reason why
and uh that's why I was asking for a
consideration in that
regard yeah the the the only thing we uh
expect is why and you've I believe
you've explained why oh I was told i'
got to be clear with the with the
speaker yeah we don't need to know the
content so much as to why you weren't
able to uh you know get it in in time oh
I apologize for that so so origin Weber
I was just going to say Mr Speaker that
um we have been very Fierce on this
Committee in a bipartisan manner uh
about bills that could have been
submitted and you know if people could
knew or could have known that they
really have a duty to get in on time but
I will say that the circumstances of
this particular case which are apparent
who had to
be with a critically ill child for an
extended period period of time are ones
that I simply uh can do nothing except
say I would be glad to move that we
allow late drafting on this bill without
any comment on the bill itself but I I
is there a second I'll secondes DEET
seconds
it um is there any further discussion
representative Smith just a quick
question why can't it be a year two
Bill why I'm sorry sir well why can't
you file it next year why does it have
to be a year one bill uh because we have
a there a critical impact happening
right now where PE where the target
market which is our 65 plus are being
forced out of their homes and they have
no no Alternatives I'm I'm a
professional realtor as well and I'm
seeing this first firsthand and I would
like to bring it to the opportunity for
some leadership with Vision on this
subject and to have it assess to the
appropriate resol not resolution but the
appropriate committee on what we can do
uh
now and as
immediately but that's
it where the
rooll I just wanted to be clear I had
representative Weber making the motion
and I missed the second representative
representa the question is to allow for
late drafting for representative command
representative Packard yes
representative Smith yes representative
duet yes representative Osborne yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative eel yes representative
Weber yes represent Sullivan yes motion
Horan thank you very much as all of you
around the table know I'm represent
Timothy Horgan from from uh from Durham
and before I begin my testimony I'll
just say as a point of personal
privilege I actually bought the jacket
I'm wearing at Goodwill as was mentioned
an hour and a half or so ago but and my
bills probably I don't have anything I
don't have any personal circumstances
that delayed it I just um I sponsored
last year HB 1075 a bill that would have
abolished daylight savings time putting
Hampshire on Standard time yearround and
that's uh topic is probably on all of
our minds right now because this we're
having some of the shortest days of the
year so
um basically I'm just trying to bring it
back now because it's an issue that seem
for some reason there seems to be a lot
of Nationwide interest in it including a
tweet from our president-elect and I I
know he tweets lots of things most of
which I don't agree with but that idea I
actually like so I think the
U and also the other thing I'll add is
the Bill had a somewhat convoluted
legislative history and I was um one of
the things I heard a lot was that this
might be best done as part of a regional
comp which admittedly there is no such
Regional compact that exists yet and
another member actually was planned to
introduce a bill with the regional
compact in it and he didn't and I didn't
introduce the bill that I introduced
last year so um that's
uh that's basically why I'm uh why I'm
uh asking you to allow me to late draft
the bill which would be a fairly simple
bill either way the question
representative is why didn't you do it
during the rig of drafting period oh
because I thought another member was
bringing a bill that would go better
with what we'd heard from the uh um our
body and then the other body which I
guess were still allowed required to
refer to by one on the other side of the
wall so it's um I just thought I I
didn't know I didn't always he coming at
the end of a meeting that's longer than
these meetings usually are and I know
you all want to go um you want to go
home and I see re and Sweeney appears to
have a question for me so I will answer
ites Sweeny Mr Speaker I move not to
allow late drafting
okay there a second yes moved in second
and not to allow okay thank you is there
discussion okay clerical caller roll
motion is to not allowed represent
Packard yes represent Smith yes
representative duet yes representative
Osborne yes represent Sweeney yes
representative Simpson yes
representative evil yes representative
Weber yes representative Sullivan yes
Z is there any other business that come
before the rules committee at this
point if not I will take a
motion oops to